When one of your first jobs is sharing the
screen with the world's favorite web-slinger,
you're bound to be a star. Peyton List's
career has only gone up from there,
and her transformation is truly stunning.
List started her career as a child model but
transitioned to acting at a very early age.
That was seemingly always part of the plan,
with List admitting in a conversation with
Brooke Shields for Interview Magazine that she'd
always been eyeing a performing career. And it
was thanks to her mother that the actor got
an opportunity to pursue her dream. She said,
"I never thought of it as a career. It started
off as an after-school thing I
would do growing up in New York."
List said that her twin brother, Spencer,
was approached first by local producers
and that her mother lobbied hard to
get her seen as well. She recalled,
"My mom said, 'Oh, well, my daughter is the
one who's always wanted to do it.' [...] And
she kind of fought for me. So, my mom is
really the one that saw that I could do it."
List would initially model in publications
like American Girl and Justice, eventually
appearing onscreen in several uncredited
roles. One of those uncredited gigs came
in 2002 via a spot in the daytime soap opera "As
The World Turns." She'd go on to book roles in
dozens of other film and television projects
before finally entering the Miyagi-verse.
If you spend a few minutes scrolling through
Peyton List's filmography, you'll find a genuinely
impressive list of titles. But if you go back all
the way to the beginning of the actor's career,
you might be shocked to see List followed her
one-off spot on "As The World Turns" with a
brief role in one of the biggest blockbusters
of the early aughts: Sam Raimi's "Spider-Man 2."
Yes, List's role in the film is
very much of the "uncredited" sort,
with the actor appearing alongside her
twin brother as a young girl chasing a
ball through the perilous streets of New York
City. The brief scene comes early in the action
when Peter Parker puts a make-or-break pizza
delivery on hold to save the young girl and
her brother from being hit by a truck. In
terms of screen time, the scene is little
more than a cameo for the baby-faced List
twins. But they do earn a line of dialogue.
"Hey, you guys. No playing in the
streets." "Yes, Mr.Spider-man."
Brief as it is, the moment remains a memorable
one in what is arguably the best "Spider-Man"
movie to date. And even at such a young age,
List's boundless charisma is well on display.
Like many other young and upcoming actors, List
had the opportunity to play a younger version of
a big-name actor. And as it happens, she'd have
quite a bit of success booking such roles in the
first decade of her career, portraying the younger
version of some major stars over that period.
One of the earliest of those roles found List
playing the pre-teen version of Katherine
Heigl's Jane Nichols in the 2008 rom-com "27
Dresses." It remains arguably the biggest
of such roles for List, not only because "27
Dresses" was a massive hit at the box office,
but because the young actor was front and
center as young Jane throughout the film's
opening flashback. Two years later, she
appeared in "The Sorcerer's Apprentice,"
portraying young Becky Barns to her elder
on-screen counterpart, Teresa Palmer.
She'd follow that gig by playing the child
version of Taryn Manning's Larissa Welsh in
a 2011 episode of "Law & Order: Special
Victims Unit." And that very same year,
List turned up uncredited as the younger version
of Kate Hudson's Darcy in "Something Borrowed."
As it was, 2011 served as a bit of a breakthrough
year for Peyton List. In film, she appeared as
Holly Hills in the beloved "Diary of a Wimpy Kid"
franchise. Adapted from the works of Jeff Kinney,
said franchise began in earnest the year
prior with the big-screen adaptation of
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid." The first
sequel — "Diary of a Wimpy Kid:
Rodrick Rules" followed in 2011, with
List's kind-hearted Holly becoming a
main player in the action after protagonist
Greg Heffley develops a major crush on her.
Though Holly and Greg were on very friendly
terms by film's end, that crush goes largely
unrequited in "Rodrick Rules." Things, however,
heat up between the pair in the 2012 follow-up,
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid: Dog Days." List
sees a major jump in screen time during
the summer-set threequel, with Holly and
Greg becoming a full-blown couple by the
time the credits roll. In case there was
any question, their journey to coupledom
is as hilarious as it is heartwarming. And
List is an absolute joy to watch throughout.
Circling back to 2011, it turns out that was also
the year Peyton List landed what was then the
biggest role of her career, fronting the Disney
Channel hit "Jessie." List didn't book the title
role on the series, instead appearing as Emma
Ross, the somewhat ditzy and fashionable eldest
child of the family Jessie Prescott cares for.
As the actor said in an interview with PopSugar,
although there were some differences between her
and the character she played on "Jessie," the two
share a love for fashion. List reprised her role
as Emma for the 2015 "Jessie" spin-off "Bunk'd"
and also appeared in other Disney shows "Austin
& Ally," "K.C. Undercover," and "I Didn't Do It."
Guest appearances aside, List played Emma for four
full seasons of "Jessie." But
as big a break as the role was,
the actor admitted to Coveteur in 2017 that she
struggled with the fact that the general public
tends to hold teen Disney stars to an almost
impossible real-world standard. She said,
"It's weird because Disney stars are normal
teenagers. Everyone expects that because they have
this show where everything is perfect — bad things
do happen, obviously — but I think they just
expect them to be really conservative and always
cover up and not really be who they truly are."
"Look, I can't really chat right now because
I've got some holes in my memory to fill."
"Hey, well that's why I'm here. I can
totally help you fill your holes."
"Excuse me?"
Perhaps in an effort to show who she really is,
after completing the 2016 Disney movie "The Swap,"
List put considerable effort into distancing
herself from her squeaky-clean Disney image.
During a 2021 chat with Interview Magazine, she
admitted that was tough in part because she'd
spent so much time making rounds with Disney
Channel fare, she'd forgotten how to audition,
and ultimately needed to relearn
how to keep calm during the process.
Nevertheless, List found herself busy during
her post-Disney career, quickly landing the
lead in the independent film "Anthem of a
Teenage Prophet." The indie drama — which
co-starred "Shameless" breakout Cameron Monaghan
and "Yellowjackets" star Juliette Lewis — was a
heavier project that showcased her range
beyond family-friendly Disney offerings.
List has continued to surprise audiences since,
including with her role as Tory on "Cobra Kai."
In a funny twist, according to List's comments to
WWD, her Disney past helped her land the "Cobra
Kai" role, as the creators of the Netflix hit
apparently couldn't pass up the opportunity
to cast a former "Disney Princess" in
one of the series' most emotionally
complex roles. That gamble has officially
paid off big time for everyone involved.
Though she's undoubtedly best known as an
actor at this point in her career, List
spent much of her pre-"Cobra Kai" time carving
out a secondary career in the music industry.
While she'd been writing songs for years prior,
List waited until she was 20 to drop her first
single, 2018's breakup anthem "Liar Liar."
As she told Nylon in an interview coinciding
with the release, she'd been holding off
recording the song for a while because,
"It took me a while to feel
super-confident and super-proud of it."
She said she also wanted to wait until her Disney
days were behind her before pivoting to music,
as she didn't want to be filed in with
every other Disney star-turned-pop singer.
List was probably wise to wait, as she's been
able to work on her music completely on her own
terms and without Disney-sized expectations.
She has, however, only released a handful of
singles and music videos to date. And with no
new tracks since 2019, one can only assume her
booming acting career is leaving little
time for the recording studio these days.
Thanks to her role on "Cobra Kai," Peyton List is
a name well-respected in Hollywood circles today.
But even if her name now conjures images of a
talented child star transitioning to an adult
career, it's worth noting she's not the only
Peyton List in town. In fact, one could easily
argue the other Peyton List has had every bit
as compelling a career to date, with that older
actor booking notable roles in "Mad Men," "The
Flash," "Gotham," and "The Rookie" over the years.
It's pretty rare that two actors
forge ahead with the exact same name,
as SAG-AFTRA rules tend to limit such issues.
It's even rarer that two actors with the same
name have the sort of success the
Peyton Lists have had. And yes,
it's almost unheard of that the two might end up
on the same call sheet for any film or television
project. Yet that's precisely what happened
in a 2002 episode of "As The World Turns," in
which the two Peytons apparently appeared not
just in the same episode, but the same scene.
The two Peyton Lists joined the screen
again together when both actors were
credited for voice performances in the
2019 animated superhero hit "Batman: Hush."
"Take care of your boss."
"Ugh, he's not my boss!"
Sadly, the two do not share any scenes in
"Hush," with the elder List giving voice to
the nefarious Poison Ivy and the younger voicing
the butt-kicking Barbara Gordon, aka Batgirl.
The film was adapted from a popular 2002 story arc
from DC Comics that found the titular baddie using
his shocking wealth of knowledge about Batman
to wreak havoc on the man behind the mask and
his allies. "Hush" debuted at the 2019 San Diego
Comic-Con the day before its streaming release,
and remains one of the best-loved of
the recent "Batman" animated features.
As for the younger List, she obviously is not
fronting the action here. But her Batgirl does
play a pivotal role in the overarching narrative.
And given how strong List is in the role,
one has to wonder why she's done so
little voice work in the years since.
List booked her "Cobra Kai" role the year before
"Batman: Hush" was released. But given that her
Season 2 debut as Tory Nichols came when
the series was still part of the YouTube
Premium slate of original programming, it's
not entirely shocking List landed the role,
as she'd already starred in a pair of original
films for the then-developing streaming service.
Those films were 2016's "The Thinning," and its
2018 sequel "The Thinning: New World Order."
The young adult dramas are a sort of hybrid
between "The Hunger Games" and "The Purge,"
unfolding in a not-too-distant future in which
overcrowding has led society to take extreme
measures in population control. In this case,
that means straight-up executing any and every
student who fails to pass a certain standardized
test. The films find List sharing the screen with
the controversy-courting Logan Paul, with their
characters discovering unsettling discrepancies
in the fateful test and eventually uncovering the
ghastly government conspiracy behind the process.
"The Thinning" films are hardly aspiring
to high art. But the audience scores for
both the original, and its sequel
are decent enough. So they might be
worth a look if you're hot to do a deep
dive on List's pre-"Cobra Kai" career.
Then came "Cobra Kai." The role of
Tory Nichols has given Peyton List an
opportunity to showcase her star power.
As the actor told Screen Rant in 2020,
she continues to have a lot of fun with the
character in what she deems a dream job. She said,
"It is the most fun role I've ever had the
chance to play. And every day I'm just like,
how did I get this? And how am
I here? I love this so much."
That joy clearly comes across as
List embodies every facet of the
character's physical and emotional
journey with disarming grace.
Playing Tory has also given List an opportunity
to develop legit martial arts skills,
which she reportedly refines during workouts
at a small, private dojo owned by the uncle of
a friend. The actor has said as well that
she finds her "Cobra Kai" role empowering
as it forces her to train so heavily. And any
"Cobra Kai" fan can attest that List puts those
skills to extraordinary use during scenes
that require her to speak with her fists.
"Come on. My sister always promised to
take care of me. She taught you better."
"Yeah, she taught me to
recognize a low-class leech."
But the actor is arguably at her best on "Cobra
Kai" when she's speaking with her voice. And
considering her origins as a child model and
Disney Channel star, List's transformation into a
fully-developed karate antagonist has proven quite
an unexpected, if most welcome surprise indeed.